estoy seguro de que a muchos les pasó
que estudiaron se formaron y llegó un
momento que tocaba elegir qué hago
dedico mi vida mi carrera profesional a
crecer en una multinacional que exige
todo mi talento mi creatividad y mi
magia a cambio de un montón de dinero o
le hago caso a eso que siento adentro un
poquito más a la derecha del corazón y
me convierto en un hippie idealista que
lucha por cambiar el mundo trabajando en
una ong
yo yo elegí la primera opciones y
dediqué durante muchos años toda mi
creatividad a varias de las marcas más
importantes del mundo probablemente
elegí la primera opción porque no
existía esta charla text mejorada de
verdad de verdad de verdad
esta charla va de entender que no es
cuestión de elegir entre ser un
profesional exitoso en una empresa o un
soñador de un mundo mejor en un
emprendimiento social no está charla va
a entender cómo crear empresas y
emprendimientos sociales cómo crear
empresas y emprendimientos que sean
rentables económicamente y que además
generen impacto social sí así que si les
parece les propongo que comencemos
analizando el contexto actual de la
mayoría de las ongs y emprendimientos
sociales el contexto y su modelo de
negocios que les propongo que desde este
mismísimo momento comenzamos a llamar
modelo de negocios del pasado de las
ongs y emprendimientos sociales
básicamente la mayoría de estas
organizaciones
es pasaban sus modelos de ingreso en
tres conceptos
el primero es las subvenciones el
segundo son las donaciones y el tercero
el trabajo voluntario algo importante y
ya les adelanto que este es un modelo de
negocios muy problemático sí muy
problemático así que si le parece
analicémoslo un poco
comencemos con las subvenciones con
subvenciones nos referimos a esa
inyección de dinero que viene por lado
del sector público que si bien es muy
necesario para el desarrollo social
presenta un problema que es muy pero muy
pero muy pero muy grave
y es básicamente que hasta el 40% del
dinero que se recibe en muchos casos hay
que utilizarlo para gestionar la misma
subvención amigos y amigas hay que
entender que esto es realmente grave
estamos hablando de no sé por ejemplo un
proyecto que se nos acercó hace poquito
que era un comedor social y nos contaron
que tuvieron la suerte de ganar una
subvención de 100.000 euros básicamente
nos contaban como de esos 100 mil euros
tuvieron que utilizar 38 mil euros en
monedas para pagarle a un pequeño
ejército de administrativos que se
encargaban de gestionar ese dinero en
vez de nada utilizar ese dinero para
ampliar su impacto social para tener más
gente en su comedor 11 otras de esas
cosas que conseguía tienen más sentido
de verdad la mejor con el ejército de
administrativos pero me parece me parece
demasiado me parece demasiado
tenemos lo que son las donaciones que
estoy seguro de que todos saben lo que
son las donaciones pero no estoy tan
seguro de cuántos saben lo difícil que
es llevar a cabo una campaña de
recaudación de fondos de manera exitosa
de verdad que es algo muy difícil tanto
que en muchos casos los proyectos
sociales terminan desviando toda su
energía y todos sus objetivos para
intentar llevar a cabo esa campaña de
manera correcta y olvidándose del
impacto social sé yo sin ir más lejos
hace un año estábamos en mexico y
conocimos un proyecto precioso un
proyecto que básicamente en un
laboratorio de estudios genéticos que
valga la redundancia así estudios
genéticos a niños y niñas con diversidad
funcional de manera gratuita el punto es
que un día tuvieron una idea y es que
hacemos una maratón social para recaudar
fondos automáticamente al día siguiente
se pusiera a producir esa carrera y pasó
un mes pasado en dos meses pasaron tres
meses
se dieron cuenta que en el último tiempo
puntualmente en los últimos tres meses
no habían hecho ningún análisis genético
a una niña o un niño con diversidad
funcional que por el contrario habían
aprendido un montón sobre producción de
carreras pero no es donde ellos van a
hacer la diferencia ni les interesa
hacer la diferencia y como este caso que
les cuento sepan que existen muchísimos
otros y que realmente es muy triste ver
cómo muchos proyectos a veces terminan
muriendo porque no encuentran la
solución a tiempo entonces hablamos de
las subvenciones hablamos de las
donaciones y ahora es el turno del
trabajo voluntario el trabajo voluntario
es ese acto tan pero tan hermoso y que
nace de un lugar todavía más hermoso que
es trabajar a cambio de la satisfacción
de estar apoyando un proyecto social es
lo digo así es suena muy muy muy hermoso
pero la realidad no es tan hermosa la
realidad es que el trabajo voluntario no
es más que una desprofesionalización del
emprendimiento social el trabajo
voluntario es saber dios hagamos una
idea digo cuánto puedo yo exigirle a una
persona que ya trabajó ocho horas en su
verdadero trabajo y todo lo que yo tengo
para decirles vamos quiero que lo des
todo a cambio de estás haciendo el bien
no no funciona o no funciona y no va a
funcionar por eso trabajo voluntario te
decimos sos hermoso pero pero no pero no
y algo importante en esta charla no los
va a dejar deprimidos esos de verdad que
se los prometo porque yo sé en este
momento están preguntando entonces qué
si un proyecto social tiene problemas
para sustentarse económicamente con
subvenciones donaciones y trabajo
voluntario entonces qué
la respuesta es muy simple crear
emprendimientos sociales es decir crear
emprendimientos o empresas que ofrezcan
productos y servicios que generen
ingresos económicos pero a su vez que
estos productos y servicios generen
impacto social sí y es algo muy
importante cualquier emprendimiento
puede ser un emprendimiento de impacto
social es algo muy importante esto no es
un acto de hippies no no no no no no no
no es más piensen ustedes mismos como
consumidores
es la hora de la merienda tienen ganas
de comer un yogur entonces van al
supermercado van a la zona de las
neveras y se encuentran que por el mismo
precio y por la misma calidad tienen un
yogurt tradicional o un yogurt social
que en su proceso de elaboración emplea
a comunidades en riesgo de exclusión
mismo precio misma calidad que eligen el
seguro tradicional o el seguro social
y si dice yo también elijo el yogur
social es más hoy mismo
hoy mismo hace un rato compré aquí mismo
en barcelona un yogurt que en su proceso
de elaboración emplea a personas con
trastornos psiquiátricos aquí mismo en
barcelona y hoy si yo es importante
entender eso es importante no es que
ustedes y yo somos unos locos que
pensamos así realmente es importante
entender que el 70% de los consumidores
elige productos de impacto social
preferiría comprar productos de impacto
social y esto se pone mejor porque no
solamente son los consumidores quienes
eligen el emprendimiento de impacto
social sino también que lo hace el nuevo
talento es decir todos aquellos
trabajadores con menos de 30 años que
pertenecen a generaciones con mayor
conciencia social también eligen
trabajar o preferirían trabajar
emprendimientos o empresas de impacto
social
otra vez piensen ustedes mismos mismo
salario mismo puesto que prefieren
trabajar un emprendimiento social un
emprendimiento tradicional
y de verdad creo que es el dato de 74%
es una nota que leí la semana pasada el
74% del nuevo talento quisiera trabajar
en emprendimientos de impacto social si
de verdad es así y algo que es
importante para que entendamos si el
consumidor elige el emprendimiento de
impacto social y el talento elige el
emprendimiento de impacto social el
inversor qué tipo de emprendimiento o
empresa va a elegir para invertir qué
creen
también eligen los emprendimientos de
impacto social es que incluso de esta
manera es que el último año se duplicó
la inversión en este tipo de
emprendimientos y empresas es por eso
que cada vez somos más los autores que
aseguramos que para el 2050 la mayoría
de las empresas y emprendimientos van a
ser de impacto social y otra vez esto no
es un acto de hippismo de verdad piensa
en ustedes mismos si lo que quieren
hacer es llevar su talento hacia un
propósito social si la respuesta es
crear o ser parte de un emprendimiento
de impacto social pero ojo para todos
aquellos que solamente les interese
emprender para todos aquellos que
solamente les interese el dinero también
la respuesta es el impacto social
si la respuesta es perseguir el
emprendimiento de impacto social es
importante amiguitos y amiguitas
entender que soy al isleño cool de
verdad social is the new cool amigos y
amigas estamos de moda lo social se puso
de moda sí de verdad y ven que esto se
va poniendo cada vez mejor yo les
prometí que no vamos a dejar deprimidos
y esto se iba a poner mejor bien
entonces seguramente ahora la pregunta
cambió y ahora la pregunta es cómo crear
un emprendimiento de impacto social para
esto es importante que sepan que existen
un montón de herramientas que están 100%
diseñadas para crear emprendimientos de
impacto social como por ejemplo en la
nymex elvin laboratorio de innovación
social que actualmente codirijo hemos
creado el triángulo de las 3 cv una
herramienta que está 100% diseñada para
crear modelos de negocio es decir
modelos de ingreso de impacto social
como vemos la herramienta lo que plantea
es un triángulo con tres preguntas una
pregunta en cada una de sus esquinas en
una tenemos a quien en otra tenemos con
qué y no tenemos con quién la respuesta
de cada una de estas preguntas nos dará
como resultado los lugares los puntos
donde se hace presente el o los impactos
social dentro del modelo de negocios si
les parece hacemos un doble clic en cada
una estas preguntas para entender un
poquito mejor de qué se trata primero
tenemos a quien en este caso la pregunta
busca que reflexionemos acerca de a
quién está dirigido el producto o
servicio que ofrece el emprendimiento es
decir que el producto o servicio
resuelve una necesidad social en el
usuario final sí como podría ser una
silla de ruedas o también un eco plugin
que modifica todos los banners de tu
browser por banners de productos
responsables algunos está preguntando
como aquí
bien no estamos hablando de un proyecto
que hemos desarrollado en learning elvin
aquí mismo en barcelona veámoslo y lo
comentamos
[Música]
muy bien en este caso greta deco plugin
lo que hace es resolver una necesidad en
el usuario final que quiere consumir de
manera más responsable pero como todos
sabemos es algo que es bastante difícil
de hacer bien esto en cuanto a a quién
pero por otro lado tenemos el con que en
este caso la pregunta lo que hace es
indagar en cuanto a con qué está
elaborado ese producto o servicio que
ofrece el emprendimiento dicho en otras
palabras estamos hablando de una materia
prima de impacto social veamos otro
ejemplo que hicimos en la remake el min
en este caso en colombia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
yo soy lo que están pensando en este
momento yo sé lo que están pensando este
momento y yo les juro que estas
golosinas estos chuches son ricos los
shows del hostel oscuro se los juro te
lo juro bien entonces hablamos de a
quién hablamos de con qué y ahora es el
turno de con quien en este caso la
pregunta nos invita a reflexionar acerca
de con quién está producido ese producto
o servicio que ofrece el emprendimiento
dicho en otras palabras emplear a
comunidades con poca inserción social y
laboral es lo que le ofrece al
emprendimiento un valor social algo que
es muy pero muy pero muy muy muy muy muy
importante a la hora de ejecutar modelos
de impacto como éste es que al empleado
se lo contrate por su talento y no
únicamente por su condición social les
digo esto porque es algo que hemos
aprendido hermosamente en méxico donde
hemos desarrollado este proyecto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué bien qué bien les dije le dije que
nos íbamos a quedar deprimidos se los
dije y acá estamos acá estamos bien pero
estoy seguro de que por algún lugar de
haber un hater porque siempre hay un
hater que en este momento está pensando
que claro desarrollar un emprendimiento
de impacto social lleva mucho más tiempo
mucho más esfuerzo y tiene mucho más
riesgo que cualquier otro tipo de
emprendimiento y eso es mentira crear un
emprendimiento de impacto social lleva
el mismo tiempo energía y riesgo que
cualquier otro tipo de emprendimiento
solo que claro el emprendimiento de
impacto social al final de cuentas te da
una satisfacción que es mucho más que lo
que puede llegar a llenar los bolsillos
si es que me permiten la analogía barata
así que ahora que aprendimos que errores
no cometer a la hora de crear un
emprendimiento de impacto social
ahora que aprendimos que hay
herramientas para crear emprendimientos
de impacto social y también aprendimos
una de esas herramientas que es
justamente para crear modelos de negocio
de impacto social
ahora que aprendimos que crear un
emprendimiento impacto social lleva el
mismo tiempo energía y riesgo que
cualquier otro tipo de emprendimiento y
lo elige el consumidor final lo elige el
talento lo eligen los inversores porque
social is the new cool ahora que
aprendimos todo esto quiero que volvamos
a imaginar esa situación que les plantea
el comienzo
estudiamos
nos formamos y llegó el momento de
elegir
qué hago
dedico toda mi vida profesional a crecer
en una multinacional que exige todo mi
talento mi creatividad y mi magia a
cambio de un montón de dinero hoy quizás
tampoco tanto
le hago caso a eso que siento en un
poquito más a la derecha del corazón y
me convierto en un profesional con
ideales que trabajan en un
emprendimiento de impacto social
apostando también a un crecimiento
económico que hago continuó siendo un
cómplice del problema o me hago cargo y
comienzo a ser un cómplice
de la solución
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]